you cannot
change their point of view right no
number of anonymously sent books
will change their mind
right though I encourage you to keep
trying
um uh you know no Angry conversations
or meetings will change it's just not
going to happen all right and so
you're barking up the wrong tree
right it's not about how do I change my
leader it's how do I be the leader I
wish I had
leadership has nothing to do with rank
rank affords you Authority that's it
but it doesn't make you a leader right
leadership is the awesome responsibility
to see those around us rise
and if you have rank
if you have authority you can just lead
at scale
and so what you want to do is be the
leader you wish you had and you were not
going to change somebody two three four
levels up who disagrees and doesn't who
ignores all of the stuff that I'm
talking about right like we've lost them
right or they'll come over they'll have
their come to Jesus moon in a different
way right which sometimes happens
but if you lead if you are the leader
you wish you had and this is why I want
to see young people if they go through
discomfort or they have a leader who's
they don't buy into please don't quit
right please stay there and practice the
difficult magical wonderful honorable
skill of leadership with your team even
if you're the most Junior person you
have somebody to the left of you and you
have somebody to the right of you and
you can commit to seeing that they feel
seen heard and understood you can commit
to helping them achieve their goals you
can commit to making them feel like
someone has their back in difficult
times you can commit to helping them and
you can commit to in helping ensure that
when they go home at the end of the day
that they feel fulfilled and they had a
good day at work that's called
leadership and when you start to find is
if you can do that if you can develop
that skill set that these little teams
start to be higher performing they start
to get along better the teaming starts
to happen really well and Leadership
will either ignore you because you're
doing fine or you they may surprise you
and be like what are they doing down
there I'm really curious they may
actually come and learn from you
and eventually one of you is going to
get promoted out of that group and go to
another team and they're going to take
all the skills they learn from you
and they're going to bring them to their
new team and now you're gonna have two
high performing wonderful teams that are
highly trusting and and magical and then
three and then five and then ten and
before you know it the tail wags the dog
and this is the one of the hardest
things I think young people struggle
with which is which is we're talking
about a long-term mindset we're talking
about an infinite mindset here which is
the speed at which it takes for the tail
to wag the dog is unpredictable the
reason a lot of businesses ignore all of
my work is not because it's wrong or
they disagree it's because they want it
to work on the day they want it to work
which is the exact same thing as saying
to me Simon I'm exercising and I need to
be healthy on this exact day on this
exact time
I'm like I mean maybe it'll work out
that way you know it's like every doctor
will tell you if you work out 20 minutes
a day for the rest of your life you're
going to be super healthy right but on
what day on what day you're healthy on
what day your blood you know your blood
pressure gets better nobody knows
sometimes quick sometimes slow I don't
know but you have to commit to the
process and a hundred percent of the
time the process works I just don't know
when
and Leadership is the same a hundred
percent it works I just don't know when
and people come quickly and people come
slowly
so you may convert an entire
organization in a year or you may just
simply build the momentum that it'll
continue without you but you won't get
to see it change that's possible too
um so but the most important thing is to
commit to the regime like brushing your
teeth you know brushing your teeth every
day brushing your teeth does nothing
unless you do it all the time every day
can I take a night off yes like you can
it won't do any damage how many nights
can I take off I don't know neither does
any dentist just not too many
right same thing commit to the regime be
the leader you wish you had don't worry
about convincing other people